When Michigan Congressman Justin Amash
announced he was leaving the Republican Party
to become an independent,
he didn’t just goodbye to the GOP--
he opened up a whole new set of possibilities
in American politics.
It's gotten worse and worse and I think this
was the term that really broke it for me.
In choosing principle over party,
the 39-year-old son of a Palestinian refugee
has become the spokesman for all Americans
who believe in limited government.
Since taking office in 2011,
Amash has been an outspoken critic of out-of-control
government spending,
state surveillance, and unauthorized wars.
He believes that Donald Trump engaged in impeachable
behavior,
but he’s primarily motivated by his belief
that Congress is no longer doing its job of
writing laws that the Executive branch implements.
"The founders envisioned Congress as a deliberative
body in which outcomes are discovered,”
he wrote in the Washington Post.
“We are fast approaching the point, however,
where Congress exists as little more than
a formality to legitimize outcomes
dictated by the president, the speaker of
the House and the Senate majority leader.”
Amash doesn’t believe the system can be
reformed from within.
I don't think there's anyone in there who
can change the system
It's pretty rigid.
It's top-down.
It comes down from leadership to the bottom.
And over the years it's gotten more rigid.
So it's more difficult now to change the process
than it was a few years ago.
This is something Amash has been consistent
on for his entire time in Congress.
He’s called out Nancy Pelosi
for straitjacketing the way legislation is
introduced, debated, and voted on in the house
while leveling exactly the same criticism
against her Republican predecessors.
The speaker has not been protecting the institution.
So you need a speaker in there who is an institutionalist,
who cares about the institution first, who
is not a partisan.
Let the house work it's will, let legislation
come to the floor,
let Republicans and Democrats and others offer
their amendments,
and let's have votes on all sorts of things,
substantive things,
not just post offices like they do now.
Modern politics is “trapped in a partisan
death spiral,” he says.
But there is a way out if Congress will actually
do its job.
There is a desire for something else.
I think the vast majority of Americans are
for that something else.
And what you have right now are two parties
that are relatively small and weak,
and, actually the reason they are so partisan
right now
is because they are small and weak.
When you get parties that are that small,
that weak,
you start to have the fringier elements of
each party rise up and make the noise.
Libertarian views are actually the mainstream
views.
If you go around my district and talk to people,
most people have generally libertarian views.
Now, would they call themselves libertarians,
would they say, "Hey, I'm a libertarian?"
Not necessarily,
but they have a set of principles that are
American principles
embedded in this culture and this society,
and they are fairly libertarian principles.
And I think we need to be able to present
that to them
and find some way to present an alternative
going forward.
I think as these parties get smaller and smaller
there'll be more independents,
and maybe a third party has a chance.
But I think the future I see is one where
there are no strong parties
and more independent candidates.
We don't really need the parties anymore.
Amash says he will run for Congress as an
independent
and is confident that he can retain his seat.
But he also hasn’t ruled out running for
president either, possibly as a Libertarian.
Whether that happens, Justin Amash has already
stirred things up
by doing what he believes in rather than what
is convenient for partisan purposes.
For that alone he deserves our attention and
commands our respect.